i love putting cameras on random things
we put a camera on an
arrow we shot one out of a cannon we put
one on the side of a car tire driving
down the freeway
we put one on a football and threw it
off a freeway well one of the ideas
we've had is to put a camera on one of
the fastest animals in the world
a falcon now we've seen cameras on the
backs of like eagles before because
they're big
strong and can carry the weight but a
falcon on the other hand would require a
very small camera such as
the insta360 go 2 which will allow us to
get some incredible footage on the back
of one of the world's fastest animals
one of my favorite things about this
camera not only is it lightweight but
it's magnetic it can stick to all kinds
of things
look at that even fire extinguishers
like you can put this in all kinds of
different areas allowing you to get a
variety of shots really rapidly
very easily you're like what can't you
stick this thing
[Music]
okay so obviously falcons are not
magnetic so i've got to figure out a way
to mount this to the back of a bird
somehow safely all right let's get to
work thanks to the community we managed
to connect
with maya higa who's a twitch streamer
and also a falconer
and she managed to give us a lot of
really insightful and useful information
including connecting us with the
falconry experience based out of paso
robles
just a few hours outside of la making it
really convenient for us to be able to
go work with these birds
but before we get anywhere on this we
have to figure out a way to actually
mount this camera to a falcon we have
two days
to figure this out how do you put a
camera on a bird
we are taking our lead from maya here
she actually emailed over some photos of
her
falcon i think his name is orion okay
look at how cute he is
so maya says that they have these little
backpacks to carry a gps transmitter so
that your bird doesn't get lost i think
it's even
part of like state law or country law
bird lies it's actually part of bird law
but this is perfect because
i was able to buy the exact same harness
that she uses
on her falcon so i'm gonna try to keep
this as the main interface point with
the falcon and just build upwards from
here
i don't want to like change this much
like if
if i if i add like some extra stuff to
the back of this i'm worried that might
be uncomfortable for the falcon like i
just don't know
i've never worked with falcons before
this guy is really cool because you can
literally take it and like literally
stick it to anything
it's like it's got a little sticky mount
that you can wash off and then gets more
sticky again
if i'm going to utilize this i have to
make some modifications
i'm being very very careful not to get
my fingers cut
[Music]
oh no okay good we're good okay
so i've now reduced that whole thing to
this little little chunk is
let's get in there that's getting very
very close
so this is pretty much it this is
supposed to go on the back of a falcon
and
hold the camera okay there actually is
one more thing i got to do here i got to
figure out how to cut the magnet out of
this
the back of this acts as like a heat
sink and you don't want to film for
longer than like 10 minutes otherwise
this starts getting really hot
the problem is at the back of this the
magnetic actual latch here
is going to stop a lot of that heat
transfer but if i cut out the magnet how
will it sit in there well i'm just gonna
take a zip tie
zip ties honestly work very well i love
zip ties
so i'm gonna make this permanent by
epoxying it to the backpack and then
we'll put the backpack on the falcon
when it's actually flying this is pretty
much what it's gonna look like it's
gonna look
just like this it's not gonna be the
most elegant looking flying camera but
it'll get you the best looking falcon
footage anyone has
ever seen and that's why i'm excited
about this
run what happened you have that look
uh i thought that these backpacks were
really easy just to put on and off of a
bird you know like
it's called a backpack i thought you
just put it on the shoulders take it off
no big deal no apparently these things
only get
taken off every two or three years
blew my mind i had no idea that's fine
but that does mean that the mount i made
and the solution i had
isn't going to work so i need a more
portable temporary solution to mount the
camera
to an existing backpack already on any
bird but
secondly these birds need practice with
the weight of the camera and the shape
of it on their back and that is
something that we can't quite deliver
right now because we've only got this
one camera
and we can't send it to him yet so what
we're actually going to do is
build a replica from scratch that weighs
the exact same amount
as the actual camera and send that to
him ahead of time so i'm going to get
the help of nat to actually design
and print an exact replica of this
camera for the falcons to practice with
i modeled a duplicate of it in fusion
360 that has
a giant void in the middle of it that
allows me to
put in weights so it's going to be
mostly aerodynamically the same and it's
also going
to be weight-wise the same the reason
why
this has to be exactly the same weight
is because birds are very uh
birdy we gotta basically replicate the
experience as close as physically
possible even have the whole
aerodynamics
down with the lens i'm actually pretty
proud of this little solution here i
literally just took a paperclip
and turned it into this harness i
soldered the uh
another paperclip thing to the side of
it here so it's like actually kind of
welded on
so you have this clip here you have the
backpack you squeeze this together and
it should go
right in boom that's not coming out so
from here i'm basically just going to jb
weld
to attach it to the little case here
has it been two hours yet no it's been
three seconds
no red this should work well it's
definitely a jury rigged solution it's
janky but i think it'll work and i think
we'll actually
be able to use this to get one-of-a-kind
footage that i have never seen before
i'm gonna pack it up put in this box we
can ship it out to them so that they can
spend the entire next week
getting their falcons used to the weight
of this camera on their back
so while the falcon is practicing let me
take a moment to explain why the go 2
has become one of my new favorite
cameras
insta360 really did put a lot of thought
into this product like there's a case
which
obviously protects the camera but it
also is a charging case because it
charges it like three times over
this is what you get if an action camera
and airpods had a baby and on top of
that it actually
acts as like this remote so you can
press these buttons to change settings
start recording it's got these little
legs that pop out so you can put it down
on the table and get your little tick
tocks like
like you do and and it's like you can
continue using this like i could just
put
all the freaking scissors and speaking
of wireless connections this can connect
to your phone
huh yep there it is look at that like i
said it's vertical or horizontal it
lets you choose you can make it square
for instagram i mean look at this
crazy and it can stick to the back of my
iphone here
oh dude your face you've got a huge nose
right now
oh my god it stabilizes the horizon so
as i do this it doesn't actually move
and it's the craziest when you throw it
in front of a mirror look at this
whoa yeah stabilization it's awesome and
once you actually get the footage onto
your phone
you can like you don't even have to edit
you can literally like select clips and
automatically select the best moments
from your clips combine it with music
and edit it on the beat it's pretty wild
so also this camera is waterproof check
this out
[Music]
hi
i love this is like my favorite camera
right now because it is so convenient
if you want to get one of these yourself
or learn more about it check out the
link in the description
so i think with all of this i think i am
finally prepared enough
to go to the falconry experience and put
this on the back of a falcon
and get some really cool footage i don't
know what to expect i'm just excited to
be around some really cool birds of prey
all right let's head out there
we made it out to the falconry
experience here in paso robles this is
anita and sammy
and we're going to work with their birds
of prey how many different kinds of
birds do you guys have
10 different species wow we have hair
socks we have a sacred falcon we have a
lantern falcon
a eurasian eagle owl he's so soft this
is softer than those like fancy soft
blankets at the store
we have a bald eagle yeah hang on
i know
not not the most graceful bird i never
expected to be slapped in the face by a
bald eagle and yet here we are
tell me more about the education side of
things that you do um we try to do
things with the kids to get them more
engaged in their environment to get them
to go outside
we're trying to inspire kids this next
generation to get outside look around
be it more observant than what's going
on on your screen
right okay so goose is the sacred falcon
and
how old is goose goose is two going on
three
let's go say hi to goose goose is
wearing a helmet
falcons are so sight stimulated that to
keep them calm
before we fly we put the the hood on
covers their eyes
but um he knows that when that comes off
it's time to fly it's time to fly so
it's kind of a conditioned response
how fast does goose go like i think the
fastest seas
dope was like 75 80 miles an hour that's
so fast though
it is like think about like you're in a
car you're speeding down the freeway but
you're coming straight at the ground
yeah that's a very funny way of putting
it i say let's go ahead and get started
let's get this thing on him he's worn it
a few times now so
okay yeah he's getting a little bit used
to it so i mean that was the entire
reason we sent this to you ahead of time
i'm so glad that worked out did you want
to do the honors
on on your bird
there we go that you make that look so
easy did you want to
tie that one up yeah
this is the closest i've ever been to a
falcon we're doing a flyby
okay this is it good luck goose
[Music]
yeah like how much energy does it take
to be able to just fly
like right like i'm going to use my arms
to propel myself
into the sky with these big chest
muscles
are you tired the problem that we're
having is a
the camera's a he's kind of trying to
figure out what's on his back
um and it might be interfering with his
wing stroke so we'll
try it again okay but also there's no
wind
right yeah and they give the term riding
the wind
a whole another meeting do they okay
yeah so in the afternoon it gets a
little bit breezier here
and once it's freezer he'll actually
like he'll take the wind and he'll let
it float him away and then he'll work
the wind
to gotcha up and down and so we'll see
how he does
so you know that classic example of
throwing a football through someone's
hooped arms
we're gonna do that with a hawk hi
aren't you cool all right so we have put
the camera on
this hawk here his name is ranger ranger
is
uh he's a funny bird and he loves to
like play games
and the more inventive we get with the
things that we do with him
the more entertained he gets he loves
just being goofy so we challenge him on
a daily basis
all right we're good to go yep
all right we're good
such a crazy feeling because they're so
silent and it's just like a gust of wind
and you'll see he shoots his feet out
forward as he comes through
just seeing those claws come out like
ahead of time
like already scouting his landing all
right now that it's been a couple hours
we're ready to fly again with both goose
and kaido
they they literally look like fighter
pilots too with those helmets
okay goosey man we got a little breeze
you want to fly
all right here's the big moment here he
goes
yeah attaboy yeah goose
[Music]
look at that
hey how you doing friend we got a uh
we got a first ac that's amazing
for me from northern africa yeah so
that's her
figuring out how to focus there we go
[Music]
what's making this possible is the fact
that the camera is so lightweight but
it's still looking like it's not quite
small enough well i mean if you think
about it
like a 30 grams would be like
adding probably another 10 pounds on to
you
here it's literally like watching a
puppy play with a ball
come on bring me the ball
can i have it now i guess the only other
thing that i'm really interested in
getting is just
some altitude if we go by the riverbed
where that hill is
well you'll get her diving down the hill
i say we try the hill
i don't think anyone's ever really
gotten any decent footage
on the back of a falcon before i i can
guarantee this is a first
really oh yeah so she's gonna fly down
to kenny and this is a this is a pretty
big drop here
kaito is good to go we're guides rolling
ready
[Music]
oh there we go
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that was great that looked amazing
that was fantastic like her going down
was pretty damn hot
that was sweet i want to as well
all right it is starting to rain and
these birds
do not fly in the rain we managed to get
a sweet shot in right before the rain
started
i'm very happy about that i'm very happy
about that
that that timing ended up working out
really well it was also supposed to rain
all day today and we ended up getting
amazing weather for the vast majority of
the day
okay so i got the footage up here on the
tv i'm gonna go grab nick because nick
has always been there every time we put
a camera on some sort of random thing
so i feel like he should see this
footage too first of all i totally got
distracted really
really do you want to see falcons hey
nick yo what's up man
uh are you looking at shrimp what no
wait what are you
doing what's up what's up um
you want to come see the falcon footage
you're a falcon i got some falcon
footage
falcon footage this is the one camera on
a blank video
that i've had no involvement in i'm
ready i'm ready to
take a flight these are bird boys in the
[Music]
back
it looks like it's almost sped up
because of the stabilization like
but no it's it's really just flying that
fast dude
they are such
that was such a good reaction
[Music]
the dynamic range in this camera is
really nice
it's going fast
[Music]
this turned out really cool congrats
thanks i'm pretty pleased with how the
footage came out this was such a really
cool experience
huge thank you to the falconry
experience check out their website they
are hosting events like what they did
for us
for anyone who wants to drop by if you
find yourself in wine country in
california
paso robles check it out if you can't
make the trip hey you know what that's
okay they're on tick tock they're on
instagram
they're posting cool videos all the time
and i expect that they'll be posting
more
sweet stuff using this camera and i
can't wait to see what they get
but for now there's only one thing that
i want to know and that is what do i put
this camera on next now that is
something so
small the options have opened up
quite a bit so leave a comment down
below suggesting what we should put this
on next
don't say i should swallow it i already
intend to do that once it gets a little
smaller
dude colon cam colon
but honestly more than anything thank
you for watching this is what makes me
so excited about the future and
technology is that like
i wouldn't have dreamed something like
this could have existed a few years ago
remember when the gopro session came out
this thing is so much better than one of
those and weighs like
so much less you know it's always nice
to go back to our roots and just
do really cool stuff with cool cameras